the tailplane is so got a hit tighter on
their 50 ad positive on the ad wall
perfect drops and AZ should have the
else
good defensive transition up it remains
now Anthony on the reverse I think it's
great dancer early game of ones that ad
will run right it
Holliday finds the right guy Anthony
Davis on the right mistakes KP once it
in rhythm van tilt pan could jump on the
route through holiday save seconded away
from Newark it's initially heat one more
once ad and he'll take the role as again
but shot clock considerations he twine
more at 80 there's the second Tangela at
seven turnovers in the third after only
six over the first two quarters of play
[Applause]
Cunningham comes up with it now Ian
Clark weak side he'll take it the hugest
defending there is never extra pass
taking it hard
thousand to the lockdown won't get the
world a he'll finally a real break for
Denver
Martin for Portland buck what's the
Playboy to be out of the break Anthony
Davis over a mean whose short out of his
hand giving taking it up McCollum man
the wall will be there ad I love that
RIM at that end of the floor